Hey there farmers and innovators. Today
we're diving into one of the simplest
yet smartest agricultural tools that's
making life easier for small-scale
farmers around the world. It's called
the manual plow tool. And trust me, this
little guy is a game changer. It's
called the manual plow tool. And trust
me, this little guy is a game changer.
But what if I told you that with just a
simple innovation, your daily tasks
could become easier, cheaper, and a
whole lot more efficient. Let's talk
about the manual plow. No engines, no
fuel, no complicated buttons or
controls. Just smart design and good old
human power. You know how some machines
are so big it feels like you need a
license just to turn them on? Well, this
tool, anyone can use it. Seriously,
grandma, your cousin, even your neighbor
who's never farmed a day in their life.
It's lightweight, so you won't be
dragging a ton of steel around the
field. And it's got an adjustable
handle, perfect for reducing strain on
your back and arms. Farmers know if your
back's not happy, you're not happy. With
its sharp metal blade, it cuts through
soil like butter. Okay, maybe not
butter, but you get the idea. It breaks
up the earth smoothly, helping you
prepare your land for planting without
breaking your bank or your back. So,
let's go over the big benefits. Low
cost, ideal for farmers with limited
budgets. Easy to use. No training
manuals needed. Portable. Carry it from
field to field with no hassle.
Eco-friendly. No fuel. No electricity.
No emissions. Sounds good, right?
Sometimes the best tools are the ones
that bring farming back to basics. This
manual plow is inspired by traditional
techniques, but with clever upgrades
that make it more efficient and
accessible. You don't need fancy
technology to get results. You just need
the right tool, and this one proves that
simplicity is powerful. So, if you're a
smallcale farmer or just someone looking
for an efficient, lowcost solution for
tilling your land, give the manual plow
a try. It's innovation made simple and
simplicity that delivers results. Thanks
for watching. If you enjoyed this video,
don't forget to hit like, leave us a
comment, and subscribe for more smart
farming ideas. See you in the next one
and happy farming.